kids don't smoke cigarettes blow bubbles
[Music]
all right so I recently mastered the
invisible snap challenge so I'm just
gonna keep mastering a bunch of cool
things on the Internet I just saw a
really cool video about making an ice
bubble it is freezing in New York right
now there's a storm called the bomb
cyclone and I thought why not recreate
that video warning I'm not crafty at all
so if I can do this anyone can I think
all you need is a straw and some soaps
and be too hard guts so do you have a
straw back here no Alvin do you know
where I can find a straw next to the
drinks that's more stronger Oh over
there it got my straws now I just need
to find a good little patch of snow it
seems like a pretty good patch of snow
right here
I saw the video it looked like you kind
of just get some soap in the tube so
that work now I think what you do is you
get low to the ground oh [ __ ] a worn
gloves I think you just blow
yeah it didn't seem to work whatsoever I
failed miserably
it's okay life is built on failures and
then you go and you succeed and you work
hard and that's the message of this
video so I did some research I figured
out what I need is a bowl and a spoon
all right that shouldn't be too hard and
that's it so I'm gonna go to tasty and
I'm gonna steal a bunch of their stuff
that's corn syrup yeah only issue is
they don't really have regular sugar or
there's real sugar back there thank you
so I got all the ingredients need to
make like a tasty setup like a little
top down thing you know I screw it you
can just record me so I need 200
milliliters of warm water which way is
warm on a sink for down I've only used
left and right sing good enough next
this is like this it's the episode of
chopped you've ever seen 35 milliliters
of corn syrup there's no even 35
milliliters thing how am I supposed to
know yeah what is corn syrup can you
drink corn syrup
not good I need another measuring cup
cuz now this one's sticky oh my god hey
cut me another measuring cup I need dish
soap I forgot my dish so if I left it
outside it looks like 35 I need another
fish drink up I need to measure the
sugar make sure if you guys want to make
these bubbles you have a lot of
measuring cups so I need 2 tablespoons
I don't need a faster tea tablespoon and
that's a teaspoon man you got me a
teaspoon just scoop it out he told me to
scoop the sugar instead of pouring it
out and we're done what I'm gonna do
right now is I'm gonna find a patch of
ice first cuz in the video it was like
on an icy surface so I'm gonna see if
that works
[Music]
so we got this nice little beautiful
patch of ice right here
[Music]
all right so I added some more soap
let's see how this works
but make a bubble it is time to get some
bubbles on the ice patch even though it
seemed like all hope was lost I was not
going to give up I decided I was gonna
stay outside till I maybe perfect ice
bubble it started to storm but I kept
blowing bubbles bubbles kept popping and
popping but I kept blowing and they kept
popping and I kept blowing and then
finally this happened I gave up I didn't
really give up I just it's freezing
outside so I'm not gonna keep trying and
failing I don't know what I'm doing so I
decided I'm gonna call the guy who
actually made the bubble video and he's
gonna tell me how to do it
hello it's good to meet you so you made
the bubble video where did you actually
blow the bubbles southern Alberta I've
been trying for a long time to figure
out how to do it and I failed miserably
so how did you do it I was using a soap
bubble solution I was using a mixture of
dish soap corn syrup as well as a little
bit of shirt that's exactly what I am
and I was blowing the bubbles using a
straw from McDonald's so I was dipping
the straw in southern Alberta we had a
temperature is about minus 25 on that
day I need about minus minus 20 Celsius
what's really been awesome this year so
many people have been freezing bubbles
it's been fun you think I can I can do
it today
that's a good sound very confident oh so
I now know how to make a nice bubble
which is an awesome the only problem is
that the circumstances aren't right it's
way too windy outside and it's actually
getting warmer in New York can't believe
how hard it is to make a bubble I can't
give up a freezer my buddy stay warm
freezes yeah so this trend is definitely
very difficult so if you're like me
don't try it on a difficulty scale from
zero to ten I would give this about a
seven also it's very uncomfortable to be
cold for
so I'm gonna bump that up to an eight
eight out of ten difficulty don't try it
if you're like me if you guys like the
video let me know in the comments below
what you want me to try and master next
[Music]